good afternoon
javier núñez fran alicante good this is
your good good afternoon a pleasure to
be here in this world
this message you can make an explained introduction
to my teeth perfect in
spanish spanish perfect spanish well then I
'm javier muñiz i'm youtube and well i
have
a  channel called memory school with
two friends josé maría sees manuel pérez
and well, on that channel and on our
memory school website we teach
mnemonics memorization techniques
so well what we do is
explain to people
how they can memorize a lot
of information in a  funnier and easier
using competition techniques well
I'm going to leave a link to your channel in
the description because I think this
could be very interesting for me
outgoing people who want to learn languages and of cours
memorizing and memorizing techniques have
omething to do  with
language learning than in your
experience that they are examples or technicians
of useful technicians  especially for
exactly in language learning
well in language learning it is
true that it is not the same as other types
of learning that we can do for
example what we work the most
is learning the syllabus because for
students people who have to learn
mathematical formulas dates  a lot of data
but it is true that in
language learning mnemonics can also help us so that it can be useful to us because it can be useful
for
several things especially when we are
starting why and you know this very
well steve when one begins to  to lose
a language what we have to do is
repeat a lot
and that implies repeating a lot repeating a
lot implies that we have to be with
our notes or with a dictionary in
front of us and reviewing many times
so we have today it is easier
with smartphones with internet it is a
lot  easier but with mnemonics
we can memorize words or memorize
their pronunciation and be able to review  r las
then because when we are on, for example,
on the bus or when we are
shopping, we can quickly make that
association and remember the word to
review la would not be something to
speak fluently but it would help us
remember to be able to do one more review
I continue if it is true that at the beginning
with a new language it is very difficult
because everything is new
for example when I learned the
characters through Chinese
I used a system of space respect
and without repetition as it says in Spanish
spaced repetition correct spaced
to learn that  it is a system of my own
that I have developed but at the
beginning I do think it can help the and we have
those ministers with a lot of repetition
but I think that effective effectively
at the beginning we have to deal with
less interesting content a lot of
unknown unknown words
then but you can explain and  more
specifically not like this one it works
perfect yes well the key would be the
memorization techniques are
always based on visual memory they are worth
remembering scenes because because we
remember very well when we are
little they teach us with stories because
we remember very well the stories and the
conclusions reached by the
stories
just like the movies we remember the stories very
well  scenes and scenes
even lead us to remember dialogues
so what we do is remember a
scene that is not especially very
spectacular or very rare for example
we always say that the scenes have
to be very exaggerated there have to be
giant animals or
explosions something  that draws a lot of
attention that captures our
imagination
for example in Spanish something that
we do because if we want to memorize for
example the word skin or pillow in
Spanish and I say for the memorization
of English Spanish in this case because
pillow we associate it with a word that is
pronounce similarly then for
example it can be pilot  or for the car an
airplane pilot
then you can imagine we
would imagine a scene with a
pilot with his cap and he arrives at the plane he
is tired but inside the cabin and
a lot of pillows he is going
all pillows they are a very strange scene  I really
don't remember the title in the
original title here in Spain it's land as best
you can
I don't remember the title but
that would be good, well imagine the pilot who
arrives very tired and throws himself on the
pillows so when he wants to
remember pillows you remember where what
scene I remember  I
automatically get that image and you know
it's the pilot and by pilot you can
get the rest of the word, yes,
well, this one costs a lot of work, like
how many words can you learn with
those techniques, well, there is a limit
because learning a language failed for me
wanting to go learn ten thousand
words twenty thousand words well in the
end
as I say it is in this case this method
is not I don't go out this is specific  mind
optimized for languages is an addit
onal resource but there is one thing that is ce
tain and that is that you can memorize much
ore information like this than peopl
think for a very simple reason and this
s an example that I always give of writi
g a scene  or narrate a scene
if you write it in a book it costs a lot
we see we go to the cinema and we see a
scene from the lord of the rings the
hobbit and quickly we are left with
the details of the landscape in a moment
if we read tolkien we see that
very extensive description to make us
we need a
very long description of that mental image but nevertheless
the brain stores
images quite efficiently we have a friend
in memory school who in fact
has them memorized memory is
specialized in memorizing decimals of
the number pi it
carries I think it is close to the  90,000
with struggles giving this system that is
amazing is a friend of ours it has
been happening to him for many years as it has for you
years he loves his hobby and he
does everything with images, that is, it is and he shows us it
is a very clear example
of what can be done, it is not something obviously it
is something that takes time and
requires more additional time but above
all this type of  Systems can
help us with two things: one to remember
those words that would otherwise be
very difficult for us because words that, because they
are longer, are more difficult for us to
memorize, this method can
help us, for example, we do not
recommend it to remember all
the words  but to remember those,
which is like hitting a wall, we
try to remember it and because it is very
long, very complicated, it doesn't
stick with us, so we resort to this type of
strategy,
well, now that I'm learning
a language, as I have to think of
scenes for each word or  there are those who,
for example, for the English, for the
Spanish, have a list of scenes
that can be used used
as how fun  talk like you do to
help people use these
mnemonics in
language learning it can be done there are several
strategies that can be used as
I say the good thing
about especially when the words are not
very abstract when we are talking
about objects talk about  a pen or
a camera the good thing is that these scenes do not need
to be grouped for
example there is another technique called
the memory palace for
which it can be used to group
within a physical place in a
room in a city  that you have
visited and put in a park in that
city where you imagine the different
scenes this would be above all for
vocabulary, maybe technical that you
need to remember certain words and
that they are grouped but for objects the
good thing is that remembering the
image of the object itself  or visualize it
that quickly the brain will connect
with the scene if I want to learn
how to say,
for example, pen is  easy if I
imagine myself writing on an exam with a
pen maybe it doesn't paint and I
get frustrated because it doesn't paint well when
I remember the pen quickly not
preventing the scene I was
describing then it's very it's more
quite automatic relatively when I
get to  there it would not be as fluid
as to talk but it would be to think for a
few seconds and the word would come to us
for me it always seems to me
that learning
similar things similar similar is more
difficult for example colors if
I have to learn colors
[Music]
and at the same time it is very difficult but if
I have for example the green grass or one
or another association with the color and with one
other thing it is easier if the same thing
with the clothes with the relatives
and all that but for a few words
those words
keyword keywords I am interested in the
history of politics so there are
words like
meeting institution proposal it
is a bit difficult to remember and that is  It would be
key words for me because it
seems many times in the conversation
every time I forget it but if there was some
way to learn those let's say in
politics 100 words
but many times it
will not be worth investing this effort
in a memorization system of course that
is  precisely what I was referring to and
for these words it has been
a good example, you have put the
colors because with memorization it is
one of the first mistakes that are made when
trying to memorize
very abstract ideas and memorizing very very
abstract ideas is complicated  the brain
recognizes very well it does not remember very well
things that it can see and touch so
that is yes for green we remember
grass or a turtle for example it is
easy or for red well a tomato an
apple fire is much simpler
and for this type of key concepts that I was
commenting on, what is done is something
similar when our students, for
example, have students who  they have to
learn laws
memorize laws and legal language is
very complicated and very abstract so
what we always try to do is
break down words into
simpler ones or look for an image that in
some way remembers
precisely that, for example
for a meeting  Well, not only to see
people gathered, but also to add
a word that reminds you of how it
begins,
okay meeting by re could be
in Spanish a beef that would be the cows
by estimation to a meeting of cows
so you know okay they are together but
what is it  a meeting is a party that
is very simplified okay it would be more
developed but the idea would be that something
that there is no place that does not give us any
doubt
well all that is very interesting
I
suggest my clients to visit your
channel because they can  improve their level of
Spanish for
many who study
Spanish
and also discover techniques that can
help in learning and memorization and also  well
in improving their level of Spanish yes as
good as we said apart before is
always learning is fun no matter
what language I know I am a
person who
personally loves learning and
I always enjoy discovering something new
so well it is always  It's fun to
develop a new skill, whether it's a
language, whether it's memorizing or, as I say,
sewing, but since you're
good, thank you very much for the
interview and we're going to continue this
conversation
[Music]